right like and people are realizing
there's certain things you can do and
certain things you can't do certain
things we accept certain things we can't
accept anymore and we're figuring it out
and we're figuring it out in real time
in at a radical pace that's never
existed before in human history
we're something that was acceptable just
10 15 years ago is completely
unacceptable now that's there's never
been a time like that before
never been a time in the entire world
since people started talking there's
never been a time where change is taking
place that's such a radical pace and
you're a part of it and I'm a part of it
and everyone is listening this is a part
of it we're all together in this and no
one knows where the [ __ ] it's going
ilove that you're you're saying that the
reason all this is happening right now
is because we are now we're just
communicating at a more rapid pace
that's all it boils down to you're
absolutely right
basic communication revolution yeah yeah
and if so if someone says you know well
oh hey you you wouldn't you said it
doesn't make sense like yeah yeah for
sure
one thing one's gonna get it right no
one's gonna get it right all the time
like no one just no I'm not an Oracle
most [ __ ] human I was born in New
Jersey right but you are being held to
that standard well we all are now is
usually something it would be there's
good to that too okay the good is you
realize like when you're responsible if
you make a mistake and or you say
something incorrect or you say something
mean they were just trying to be funny
to came out bad the the blowback lets
you know this is how people feel about
that and it's disproportionate because
your signals disproportionate your
ability to express yourself is
disproportionate so the blowback is
going to be disproportionate as well so
it feels awful but that's just an
affirmation just letting you know okay
this is not what and and sometimes
people are completely wrong about like
you know white girls can't wear hoop
earrings it's cultural appropriation
there's bad signals out there's a lot of
bad signals you know where you're racist
if you wear a kimono you slaughter like
really dumb bad signals but there's also
a lot of exchange and and it'll all work
itself out we just have to be really
careful we don't Lynch a lot of people
along the way like that would that we
don't get convinced that our
ideas are 100% the way things should be
and that we listen to all these various
ideas whether it's ideas about trans
people or gay people or women or men or
anybody you know like it's it's like
it's super important now that people
think before they act and that they
think before they cast judgment that we
have to communicate because there's
things are [ __ ] flying at us like
fish coming down a river and you're
trying to catch them with your hands and
there's just too many of them do you I
mean you're broadcasting every single
day for hours do you say things
sometimes that come back I mean I know
you say things that come back to haunt
you or you said this and that was wrong
that you said that and this is why
you're wrong do you do you ever catch
yourself and go oh yeah I shouldn't have
said that definitely all time what do
you do with that like that's what I made
a mistake I misspoke right but not this
time was yeah good Oracle if you keep
talking people go oh I get it
Nikki's just a person that says things
sometimes yeah but you don't mean to say
dumb things but you're like being a
human being is just a flawed exercise
like we're super flawed and we're
working with language which is are a
really awkward way to express intent
you know it's awkward this just you
sometimes the right yeah yeah sometimes
the right words not there for you and
you use a lot of likes and um so it's
like like like in people like like what
we're listening there on the [ __ ]
stair climber and they go you shut the
[ __ ] up you talk too much you complain
too much and you know their signal like
they're mad that they don't have a
signal so they're [ __ ] screaming at
you for your flawed signal you have a
responsibility you know there's a
there's a lot going on